we'll be welcoming today Eugene Maria
shulock he serves at a as a lecturer at
the University of applied sciences in
viener newshot Austria the recipient of
a PhD in Philosophy from the University
of Vienna Dr shulock is the founder of
the Society of Applied philosophy at The
Institute of philosophical counseling a
consulting firm specializing in
philosophical issues a former head of
the Department of philosophy at Seaman
Academy of life he taught at the Phil
philosophical Institute of the
University of Vienna for many years in
2005 inspired by The Works of Hans
Herman hop Dr shulock began a study of
the Austrian School of Economics which
led to the publication of the Austrian
School of Economics a history of its
ideas ambassadors and institutions
co-authored by Herbert unen kofler
please join me in welcoming Dr
shulock
thank you good
evening
so um it is advisable to go back to a
time before the founder of set School of
economic thought kle manga published his
gr sets at the FKS Richard in English
principles of economics in
Vienna in the 19th century was a city
expanding very quickly from 1820 to 1830
the share of inhabitants not born in
Vienna had already grown from
9.5 to
30.5% in
1856 that portion had grown to
44% during the 19th century the
population grew
Sevenfold Vienna became a
Metropolis the fourth largest city in
the world after London Paris and New
York it was not until that Berlin edged
ahead leaving Vienna to occupy fifth
place for a long
time soon to be apparent changes within
the city resulted in animated
discussions even heated
arguments every week brought a new
surprise first here and then there some
favorite spots of old of the old vienes
vanished the of daily newspapers
were filled with cried of
Anguish a particularly controverse event
was the demolition of the old stronghold
ring part of the medieval defense
mechanism built to protect Vienna from
incoming incoming
enemies following the demolition of the
stronghold ring was the construction of
the famous
ringas and here she
is the m the magnant boulevar more than
3 miles long was ceremoniously opened on
May 1st
1865 among the elal eligible eligible
eligible voters of Vienna
a liberal attitude became the
predominant political
Trend this mindset came to expression in
the December constitution of
1867 in which the relationship of
Citizen and state was cified and a
catalog of basic individual freedoms and
rights still valid to this day was laid
down and one Freedom granted by the
Constitution that turned out to be
especially important for the Austrian
School was that for the first time Jews
were allowed to travel freely within the
Empire a positive economic climate was
created after two exceptionally good
harvests this positive Economic
Development followed an increase and the
money supply that was carried through to
finance the war against
Prussia when Emperor France yoseph lobed
by the business and Society Elites
authorized the holding of a world
exhibition in 800
1873 already excessive economic
expectations were furtif fired
up the whole social life life of the
city of the old Imperial City was turned
upside down the previous humble coziness
was
replaced with a sometimes quite pompous
and imposing
extravagance experts and economists
warned emphatically in public speeches
against the stock market Swindle and the
corruption of the
press in the end
the opening of the world exhibition on
May 1st
1873 became the Overture to an
inevitable admission of complete
failure the exhibition Halls were not
yet completed the weather was changeable
and the numbers of visitors remained
below
expectations many business aspirations
shattered abruptly against reality and a
week later the vienes stock exchange
recorded 110 insolvencies and on the
next day Black Friday the great crash
ensued with additional companies
collapsing by the end of the
year 48 Banks eight insurance companies
two railroad companies and 59 industrial
firms had gone into liquidation or had
even gone
bankrupt at that time in order to
graduate as an economist in
Austria one had to complete a course in
law of which the history of law was a
substantial part the students were
coached above all in analytical thinking
linguistic precision and
logic in contrast to that
calistic the state is pyo economics that
was being taught at German
universities was based on a
predominantly descriptive empirical
approach evident from the an anic breath
of the cause
alone areas of study ranged from farming
agriculture mining in trade and Industry
to finance political science and
government accounting and the program
was closely associated both both
institutionally and
methodologically with the Natural
Sciences one consequence of the boom of
the grara was a massive lack of
professors Vienna was then the
the largest university in the
world now this is where we came or we
come to
klea the founder of the Austrian
School klea was born in
1840 in Novis in
Galicia then part of the austrial
Hungarian Empire nowadays part of
Poland like most other members of the
School manga's
family was part of the new
nobility somewh in late summer of
1859 young cuddle manger moved to
Vienna and tradition has it that manga
at that time the time of the great crash
while working for the venet siton this
is the oldest vienes newspaper published
continuously to this day
witnessed some major discre
discrepancies between the traditional
price theories and the factual stock
market
prices building on his
insights he in
1867 started to work on
his the FKS WT in English principles of
economics
maanga began his economic
analysis at the level of the individual
and its
wants as such this would have been
revolutionary revolutionary enough with
most other German speaking economists of
the late 19th century thinking in terms
of the
society or the people but manga to
together with William Stanley Chans and
Leon VRA part of the Triad of the
marginalist Revolution proceeded in the
most clear way of the three
revolutionaries to describe the
principle of utility value and price in
purely subjectivistic
terms every individual fora has
wants which are purely
subjective being equipped with a mind
capable of reasonable thinking the
individuals realizes that there are
certain things or D as manger called
them that are capable of satisfying the
individuals wants in other words they
have
utility one of manga students Fred V
Visa would be the first to use the N
common term marginal
utility to put it in the words of or BM
from bar another student of mangas the
value of a good is determined by the
extent of its marginal
utility mangad them goes to divide Goods
into Goods of lower or first order the
that being consumption goods and goods
of higher
order the latter are only able to
satisfy individual ones
indirectly and thus have no value on
their own but only obtain value through
importation I have Illustrated the
process of production and value
importation here with the schematic
production of
bread step byep step in a deductive
manner Mana building on his theory of
goods value and
importation proceeded to the theory of
exchange where two individuals give up
Goods that to them have lower subjective
value than the goods they will
obtain adding money to his analysis with
money being the generally excepted
except medium of
exchange manga arrived at a theory of
money prices that up to this state is
the basis for all catallactic
Theory it was perhaps the great stock
market crash of
1873 that would lay the groundwork for
the positive reception of the principles
manga's main
work the only one who seemed to have
directly grasp grasped the
groundbreaking nature of manga's
principles was Gustaf
scha a representative of the younger
German historical
school what
followed was what would be later be
tered the metod or dispute in
method
it was in this
dispute what a young school of
economists received its name as the
Austrian
School as already
mentioned economic science in the German
Empire was mostly of empirical
nature manga expounded his
methodological View
English investig investigations into the
method of social sciences with a special
reference to the economics from
1883 manga
argued that the theoretical
economics was able to postulate exact
laws
furthermore he argued that economic
phenomena by which he mean things like
law language markets prices interest
rates and even money were natural in the
sense that they came to existence caused
by the self-interest driven actions of
individuals manga's methodological
position was wholly incompatible with
that of scha and the German historical
school they thinking in Aggregates like
the nation or the people argued that
there are no exact economic laws
whatsoever rather that all economic
science is supposed to be M collecting
of historical facts and then afterwards
trying to interpret these facts
according to them without any bias
allegedly caused by pure economic
theory the term met toen disputing
method as we see is not really
accurate since the dispute was not about
what the appropriate method of Economics
should be but rather it was about the
question of whether of whether there's
such a thing as economic theory at
all schor's
reaction to point out just one was the
most fierce in nature he called manga
book smart naive and alleged that he
lacked Universal philosophical and
historical
education manga's response the is
historism in the Dutch naal economy the
errors of historicism in German
economics from
1884 contained atomm criticism and more
severe attacks on scha he even
questioned schor's Integrity To quote
manga like no other Schooler in Germany
scha was inconsiderate in his choice of
means a master of both a personal as
well as walar style a prototype of the
problematic nature in
Academia so the methoden Str far from
being over went on for two more decades
generating over 50 relevant titles
mostly dealing with the classification
of economics the function of the
subdisciplines the re-evaluation of the
classical
economists the emergence of social
institutions and the interplay of
theoretical and Empirical research
individualism and collectivism as well
as induction and
deduction the mostly positive reception
of the
principles enabled Mana manga to attain
a non-tenured position at the University
of Vienna in
1873 after attaining a full
professorship in
1879 manga began training young
academics he assisted over a do
Hab that's a term um you don't have it
in in in in English it's a postdoctoral
degree necessary to teach as a professor
and he was involved in five further
habil in related subject
areas his students considered him an
excellent
teacher he even allowed them access to
his private
Library under his students were amongst
others
Robert Meer Emil Saks a
filipovic Victor Matia Gustaf gr Robert
sule Richard Schuler Fred V visa and a
from B all of which published Works in
mangas tradition in the 18
1880s and the years
thereafter the two students of manga
that had the most lasting effect on AUST
Austrian Theory
there were freed from visa and I from
B due to my limited time in any case I'm
only going to giving a more closer look
at the latter two men visa and
bmak let it be said
nonetheless that the
contributions of all men just named
warrant a detailed
Examination for those interest a more
complete history hisorical overview of
this man can be found in the book I have
written together with her un ker
published by The mises
Institute FR V Visa was born in Vienna
in
1851 the fourth of nine children Visa a
lifelong friend of
B presented his hilon thesis in
1884 origin laws of economic
value going further than
manga he interpreted costs as foran use
or as opportunity
costs and introduced the term gr nutson
marginal utility to economics
later anyhow Visa turned more and more
to sociological
questions after retiring from his
lecturing duties Visa lived in seclusion
he put together his work on sociology
and political science in his marlum Opus
G the law of power
1926 the following generations of the
Austrian School would largely consider
him not a part of their camp but rather
as belonging to the losan
school which can be traced back to Leon
VRA this is where we come to a from
B in Austria hardly any other Economist
has achieved the same kind of Fame as
BMC although much of his prominence
stems from the fact that his portray was
printed on the 100 Shilling note that
was in circulation between 1984 and
2001 and here it
is the third of four children hen bur
was born in Brun in 1851
he met fredi V Visa with whom he would
develop a lifelong
friendship with the help of CLE manga
the two friends received two years two
years stens to study at the universities
of laik yena and heidleberg that's in
Germany where BM dealt for the first
time in a seminar paper with the subject
that would occupy him for the rest of
his life the relationship ship between
the present and the future it's his main
theme Bak was the first of Kanga
students to receive his
habil in the same year the young leurer
and civil servant married his friend
sister baronessa paon
Visa the same year saw the publication
of History
and critique of Interest Theory
1884 in which he dissected practically
all the theories of capital interest
with tremendous rigor and
astuteness though announced to be
published quickly thereafter the second
volume was delayed one reason being
bmb's election to dean of
Faculty with his easy to read and
Polished positive Theus Capital positive
theory of capital
1889 bmak was able to distinguish
himself as the s sword of the new
Direction and made a crucial
contribution to the further promulgation
of the Austrian
School the English translation
established bu's International
reputation
between
1895 and
19004 he was Finance Minister three
times his Maxim was that the finance M
Minister should always be prepared to
resign but at the same time should
always behave as if his desire was never
to resign and he resigned from the post
permanently when excessive demand
from the military finally threatened to
strain the
budget as a professor at the University
of Vienna bmb's lectures were considered
masterpieces thanks both both to his
systematic Clarity and calm
presentation among those who lat who
later met in his seminar were such
eminent names as lutic for
mes France V
richardg Felix Som Amy Le rol filing AO
power Nikolai bharin and Yosef
scheta a from Bak died at the age of 63
while on vacation in tyell in August of
194 one month before World War I was to
destroy the Austria he fought he thought
to he fought to
preserve y yoseph AR
schuma born in
1883 in Tish Today part of the Czech
Republic one of the most well-known
economists of the 20th century is one of
the Geniuses brought about by visa and
bmak most austrians would only consider
schuma rather Loosely connected to their
camp and more in the tradition of the
mathematical laan
school nonetheless shum's role in
propagating the Austrian insights in the
anglosphere can hardly be
underestimated together with Frank
Albert feta one of the Forgotten Giants
of
Economics he was one of the earliest
Austrian School economists teaching at
you at us
universities his personal life being
rather dubious shum's contributions to
econom economics are nonetheless of
immense value his work on business
Cycles economic development of
capitalist economies the history of
economic thought and his teachings at
Harvard University in the 1930s
influenced well-known economists like
Paul Samuelson Fritz mlop and even
socialists like Oscar
Lang in fact his theory of creative
destruction to name just one of his
contributions is well known Shuma died
in
1950 in tanik
Connecticut
in both his
principles and his classic article guil
money from
1892 manga considered whether money
developed without any agreement without
legislative compulsion and even without
regard to the public
interest according to him money had a
natural origin and is not an invention
of of the
state but things changed abruptly with
the sensation caused by the scis
literally public theory of money
195 the work of g f knap from Strasburg
a statition a statistic statian and
agrarian economists of the historical
School knap saw money purely as a creat
of the legal system based on an act of
The Sovereign and having nothing to do
with an agreement within
Society kap's thesis clashed
irreconcilably with manga's evolutionary
thesis in his
1912 hiltion thesis theor scales the
umov midle theory of money and credit
ludik f m as a student of
bbx had applied the principle of
marginal utility to monetary theory in
order to return the theory of money to
the study of
Economics he
avoided the alleged Vicious Cycle in
explaining the utility of money with the
so-called regression
Theory
then evaluating money the individual
proceeds from a notion of purchasing
power derived from previous
exchanges and those earlier exchanges in
turn were influenced by even earlier
exchanges in theory these experiences
can be traced back to distant Pas times
in which money still had a purely good
character as a means of
exchange that's young
misus mises's theory of the business
cycle was mainly built on bmic theory of
capital and on Wix cell's distinction
between the natural rate of interest and
the monetary rate of
interest the former the natural rate
would appear in A B economy economy
meaning one without intermediation of
money when supply and demand were in
accord Banks can expand the money supply
by issuing fucer media money not backed
by actual savings and thus lower the
money rate below the ual
rate artificially lengthening the
structure of production the new cheap
money creates an artificial boom that
inevident has to end in a slump with the
economy being left
impoverished when Mis has published a
new edition of his theory of money and
credit 12 years later his analysis had
evidently already been confirmed by the
collapse of some of the European
currencies both Germany and Austria had
gone after the Gold Standard completely
while preparing for war and not without
encouraging acclamation from renowned
economists World War I was finally Ed by
a limitless expansion of the money
supply inflationism wrote mises in the
prease for the second German edition of
his theory of money credit
quote was the most important important
economic element in this war ideology
quote members of the Austrian School
spoke out in the daily papers and
professional journals
against the evil of inflation again and
again with Ludwick V mises leading the
way mises blamed the post-war crisis on
the unrestricted expansion of
credit since Banks and politicians had a
common interest in further lowering the
interest rate to faciliate cheap money a
money system independent of the liberate
human intervention should be
established as the monetary
ideal this would mean a return to money
backed by
gold it was about that time that ludik
Von mises cultivated his legendary
private seminar as an uncared lecturer
at the University of
Vienna it became the nucleus from
monetary and business cycle research and
gained an international
reputation Fred auston haek soon to
become the person upon whom the hopes of
the Austrian School would
rest had already considered the
questions of currency policy and
business cycle
data H became the first head of theia
Institute for Austrian Institute for
business cycle
research in hisil
thesis named SC Theory and con Theory
monetary Theory and a trade cycle from
1929 Hayek like mises
assumed that the ups and downs of the
business cycle are invariably caused by
credit
expansion an expansion of the money
supply claimed haek quote always brings
about a
falsification of the pricing process and
thus a misdirection of production
quote credit expansion is fueled by the
bank's business model as they want to
provide their customers with as much
liquidity as
possible the interest demanded by the
Banks is therefore not natural interest
or in high ex terminology an equilibrium
rate of interest but interest that is
determined by the bank's liquidity
considerations in December of
28 Hayek already came to the conclusion
that the US was on the brink of a severe
economic
slump in October of
1929 the Great Depression Did In fact
appear with full
vehement it became clear however that
differences within the school began to
grow when misus began to view economics
more and more as an apriori
science even haek no longer wished to
follow mises's philosophical shift and
gradually moved away from him in terms
of
methodology the old
polarities represented by bubic and Visa
regarding the methodology of economic
theory were revived and forces
divided hke became involved in several
disputes his literary F Feud with KES is
well
known it was so intense that letters
were even exchanged on Christmas Day we
heard
yesterday KES disputed the capacity of
the market to regulate itself
and recommended interventions to guide
the economy in the currency
system HCK rejected the notion
emphatically seeing in these very
interventions the cause of the
crisis hike was able to hold his ground
during the intense debates and Canes
deluded or even revoked some of his
positions during the this period period
however due to a fundamental
reorientating in English economics the
charm of the Austrian theory of money
and business Cycles had already already
begun to lose its freshness in the
leure the Austrian School had been
Paralyzed by the political events of the
times and its reaction to Kansas's
general theory of employment interest in
money from
1936 if there was any reaction at all
was spiritless or
subdued looking
back Hayek would call it his greatest
strategic strategic
mistake not to have taken a more
extensive stand on Kansas's general
theory it would be more than two decades
before Henry hlit an American inspired
by the Austrian School would submit the
general theory to strong criticism in
his book The failure of the new
economics the aan school had become a
little regarded
Outsider Council republics were
established in Hungary and
Bavaria according to the Russian Soviet
model in 198 and
1919 violent revolts erupted in many
places in Germany and
Austria ludik F mises who at that time
was a civil servant in the Chamber of
Commerce of lower Austria recalls the
following
quote people were so convinced of the
inevitability of
bolism that their main concern was
securing a favorable place for
themselves in the New Order Bank
directors and
industrialists hoped to make good
livings as managers under the
bists Oto
power was state Secretary in the foreign
department at his time the leading ustr
Marxist and later chairman of the
nationalization
commission mises knew him very well they
had both attended BBC's economic seminar
together to quote mises
again at the time mises wrote in the
winter of 1918 1919 in his Memoirs at
that time
I was successful in convincing the
Bowers that the collapse of a bolshevist
experiment in Austria would be
inevitable in a very short time perhaps
within days I knew what was at stake
bism would lead Vienna to starvation and
Terror within a few days plundering
hords would take to the streets and a
second blood bath would destroy
what was left of VI culture
quote after discussing these problems
with a b and his wife a devoted
socialist and feminist
activist mises was finally able to
persuade them of his
view so he saved the
country during the course of the
nationalization
debates mises defended private property
and the market economy with the argument
of economic efficiency of
Supply but he had to argue the position
almost
single-handedly since many members of
the asan school joined the statist camp
due to their positions inside the
government it almost seemed as if they
had over the course of their careers
completely forgotten that the academic
opposition to Marxism had at no
University been so profound and
productive as it had been in
Vienna mises made the point that
rational economic managements that is
resource conserving production and
distribution of goods which takes
consumer preferences preferences into
account can only be guaranteed with a
free Price system the free exchange of
goods and freedom to implement all
possible use of goods and that with
Central
planning these goals can never be
achieved if the means of production are
not privately owned then efficient
business leadership and the consequent
satisfying of consumer interests cannot
be ured
ensured socialism therefore is not able
to
calculate this is the main assertion of
mises's argument otherwise known as the
calculation problem Mr kurzner told that
yesterday in
detail mises did not allow for the
argument made by many buis economists
and
intellectuals that socialism could not
be realized because humans were still
too underdeveloped in a moral
sense according to mises socialism would
be bound to fail not because of morality
quote but because the problems that the
Socialist order would have to
solve present UNS superable intellectual
difficulties
in count just to mises hiek emphasized
the indispensable information function
of Market induced
prices for hyek a market system has a
greater knowledge of facts than any
single individual or even any
organization during the heated debate
the austrians were hardly a aware of the
fact that Hayek and mises were pursuing
two ultimately different
paradigms let us go back in time again
to the beginning of the first world
war active involvement of aan school
members in the administration of the
state reached his culmination precise
precisely in the years of the so-called
war and trans and transition economy
between 1914 and
198 this was especially calamitous for
the Austrian School it never before had
such opportunities to influence others
but failed to use
them aside from holding top positions in
public administration and in the Press
members of the school were found in the
Chamber of Commerce and in higher
echelons of large Banks and Industrial
conglomerates International as isolation
that had developed during the war
further paralyzed the Austrian
School the war had now destroyed the
extensive network of
contacts even more far-reaching and no
less devastating were the effects of the
Great social changes that occurred
during and after the first world
war members of the Austrian School
stemed predominantly from the nobility
or from the educated and propertied
middle classes and some had only
recently been giving
titles in the words of UR B quote they
were they were the true Losers of the
war
quote originally the ruling classes of
the Hops B
monarchy who now saw themsel exposed to
Progressive material impoverishment as
well the second edition of Fred Von
Visa's social econ economics remained
largely
unaltered the new edition of manga's
principles in
1923 compiled by manga son Carle also
remained the same in many ways as such
is documented the standstill which had
Arisen in the school in the
meantime the term marginal
utility long since established was
curiously enough not mentioned even
once marginal
marginalization within the university is
establishment forced the scattered
remnants remnants of the Austrian School
and its new generation to attempt
reconvening outside of the
universities private initiatives like
the misus CH and high ex Guist gra were
founded mises's private seminar was
without doubt the most important
training arena for the asran
school important problems of Economics
social philosophy sociology logic and
the epistem
epistemology of the Sciences Of Human
Action were
debated the private seminar soon became
an established in
institution all members of the Austrian
School frequented the seminar with a few
expect with a few
exceptions the main topics were monetary
Theory methodology
methodology and questions concerning
econom economic Economic
Policy during these years the aan school
intensified its contact with foreign
economists by recurrently inviting them
to lectures or events particularly to
those at the mises privat seminar
or at the naal econom economy Society in
Vienna but the
1930s personal and academic connections
with the English speaking World already
served as link to professional careers
outside the
country hi and Rosenstein Rodan received
appointments in
London in the same year and Haba
accepted an invitation to
Harvard faced with
censorship The Advocates of the Austrian
School finally gave up their attempt to
influence public
opinion the seriousness and hopelessness
of the situation had in the meantime
been demonstrated by mises's relocation
to swissland in
1940 where he was at least able to
obtain a very very well paid teaching
post after that the vienes privat
seminar ceased to
exist at the universities all lecturers
and professors who were either Jewish or
otherwise disliked by Nazis lost the
license the license to teach among them
schula Hava and
Moran the Austrian School effectively
ceased to exist on Austrian soil by the
end of the
1930s those members of the school that
decided to stay in Austria like Leon IL
and Richard vrig retreated into what was
later to be called inner
immigration academic productivity
declined dramatically and almost came to
a standstill at the beginning of the
second World War
although most of the Austrian economists
had left Vienna by the late
1930s the Austrian School lived on the
two most important members of the school
that led it through the years after the
second world war and carried on the
Austrian tradition were Fred AUST V
Hayek and ludik V mises both of which
will will be dealt within more detail
during the
conference
so um I especially want to thank Hills
College for giving me the opportunity to
speak here today and also I want to
thank the audience for their attention
and I want to specially thank Mr
PUK who proved to be very helpful in
existing me uh with preparing my talk
thank
you
thank you Dr sh you have time for a few
questions please raise your hand and the
microphone will be brought to
you sir are you aware that in America
today we are $20 trillion in
debt and I'm wondering do you you think
we will have to go through a recession
or perhaps even a depression to get
straight again because I don't know
what's going to happen with uh with our
economy I suspect the rest of the world
maybe not as bad but also deep into
debt so America is 20 trillion dollar in
debt not million not billion but
trillion so so I don't know what going
to happen
too
um but I I think the people that will
produce that that that kind of money are
very clever yeah and they have they have
they have a lot of of specialists around
them to make it that
way and
we
uh we we mostly don't don't know how
long it will last till the collapse
came uh within the Austrian School we
all thought it would it would have it
would should be happened or that should
be happened long years
before yeah and this is not possible to
to make it at that long that long time
but we all see it is
possible so I don't
know
no last night uh Professor Israel kirner
mentioned the uh German historical
school and scholer and you also
mentioned them is there a reason uh well
I should ask first at what point did
this school cease to have influence in
economics do you believe and is there
reason or can you point us to something
that we should preserve as a concept or
idea that is valuable from this school
or can we simply make it a historical
footnote
um the historical the German historical
school um German German yeah German the
German historical school
um invented the idea that economists
should serve a government no uh and the
uh in in in this in within this this
school uh all the economists uh want to
have
jobs uh uh uh within the government to
work together and fulfill their needs
and
wants um and I think uh uh uh the
thinking of canes we heard yesterday um
is one result of of of of the work of of
the German historical
school and the second the second is that
this school um
was
convinced that there is there are no
economic laws at all no so econ economy
or the the the discipline of economy is
a kind of game you can move in this way
moving this way moving another way uh
and to to bend it like you want yeah
there's no no spine no no exact law
that's that's uh
that's her
influence and so so this schol was the
the
the uh hardest enemy of the Austrian
School from the
beginning is there anything left of the
oran school we had Ben bananki now we
have Janet jellum in my opinion economic
illiterates and uh Krugman Paul Krugman
famous economist writer for the New York
Times he believes if you burn down a
city and rebuild it you create jobs and
prosperity that's the extent of our
economists today no wonder we have 30
$20,000 20 trillion deficit with
economists like that mhm is there
anything left anything left of of
mangala and and their way of thinking
now in in in Austria uh there's nothing
left from the assard school in my
country yeah so I I I grew up and I
never heard anything about the school
and by
coincidence I heard from France 50 from
Friends France 50 years ago about the
existence of the school in my country
and all all my professors at the
University they all they
keep uh their mouth shut about that
because they're paid from the Socialists
and they they lose their jobs if they
teach mes and and haek so you are lucky
that that it's possible to do that in
your country in my country it's not
possible
no and I lost I lost a lot of lectures
at different universities because I I'm
interested in these themes no we don't
America but in America you you have a
community you look look here yeah man
that's someone something yeah that's
something earlier you mentioned the gold
standard I wasn't sure where you said I
thought that ludic Vana stood on the
gold standard I'd like to elaborate a
little bit on that excuse me the gold
standard yes I I wasn't sure from your
talk where you thought ludic Von me's
stood on that
issue yeah he he as as it was a boy uh
he he was uh the gold standard was
established in the Habsburg monarchy
yeah and then uh because of the uh first
world war the gold they they they closed
the the idea of the gold standard shut
shut it up and um it it remained as a
ideal as a as a idea within the Austrian
school till today that it that it would
be the best uh to to to
um um would be the best to to uh to back
money and gold to to to um avoid uh
inflation we have time for one more
question good evening Dr shock thank you
so much for coming out to hillso college
and speaking to us this evening so my
question for you goes to your discussion
of the debate that occurred between lud
Von mises and Otto Bowen could you
discuss a little bit more about L Mis
and a bow I
think Bower I'm sorry OT
Bower
theal B yeah yes sir yeah so if you
could walk us through some of the
arguments that took place during this
debate and what in particular um were
the main points that mises was used
employed to actually persuade
of his Viewpoint thank you sir um
there's a problem uh there's only one
witness of this talk and this is and
this is Mis of itself yeah and he wrote
in his um memoirs about half a
page and that's that's uh not not not
special more than I than I told
you so um um what he wrote is that there
was there were two or three
Knights uh he sat together in in a
living room of the
bers and he convinced uh them and so he
saved the money from from from uh uh
communism and it was it was at the
winter of
1989 and the Spanish Flu was in Europe 2
million death people nothing to eat last
war and then communism that would be
really the end and so mises misus I
think is really a big hero but there's
only only one
witness himself
[Applause]
yeah thank
you